dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly failure I get a lot
of messages from you fellow scholars
that you would like to get started in
machine learning and are looking for
materials words fail to describe how
great the feeling is that the series
inspires many of you to start your
career in research at this point we are
not only explaining the work of research
scientists but creating new research
scientists machine learning is an
amazing field of research that provides
us with incredible tools that help us
solve problems that were previously
impossible to solve neural networks can
paint in the style of famous artists or
recognize images and are capable of so
many other things that it simply blows
my mind
however bear in mind that machine
learning is not an easy field this field
fuses together the beauty rigor and
preciseness of mathematics with the
useful applications of engineering it is
also a fast-moving field on almost any
given day ten new scientific papers pop
up in the repositories for everything
that I mentioned in this video there is
a link in the description box and more
so make sure to dive in and check them
out if you have other materials that
helped you understand some of the more
difficult concepts please let me know in
the comments section and I'll include
them in the text below first some non
scientific texts to get you in the mood
I recommend reading the road to super
intelligence on a fantastic blog by the
name wait but why this is a
frighteningly long article for many but
I guarantee that you won't be able to
stop reading it beware Nick Bostrom's
super intelligence is also a fantastic
read after which will probably be
convinced that it doesn't make sense to
work on anything else but machine
learning there is a previous two minute
papers episode on artificial
superintelligence if you're looking for
a teaser for this book now let's get a
bit more technical with some of the
better video series and courses out
there
Welsh Labs is an amazing YouTube channel
with a very intuitive introduction to
the concept of neural networks andrew
inc is a chief scientist at by do
research in deep learning is wonderful
course is widely regarded as the
pinnacle of all machine learning courses
and is therefore highly recommended
Nando de Freitas is a professor at the
University of Oxford and has also worked
with deep mind his course that he held
at the University of British Columbia
covers many of the more advanced
concepts in machine learning regarding
books I recommend reading my favorite
holy tome of machine learning that goes
by the name of pattern recognition and
machine learning by Christopher Bishop a
sample chapter is available from the
book if you wish to take a look it has
beautiful typesetting lots of intuition
and crystal clear presentation
definitely worth every penny of the
price I'd like to note that I am not
paid for any of the book endorsements in
the series when I recommend the book I
genuinely think that it provides great
value to you fellow scholars about
software libraries usually in most
fields the main problem is that the
implementation of many state-of-the-art
techniques are severely lacking well
luckily in the machine learning
community we have them in abundance I've
linked a great talk on what libraries
are available in the strengths and
weaknesses for each of them at this
point you will probably have an idea of
which direction you're most excited
about start searching for keywords make
sure to read the living hell out of the
machine learning ready to stay up to
date and the best part is yet to come
starting to explore on your own thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time